foreign
[Applause]
these gestures can sometimes be used as
a strategy distracting their opponents
and making them lose their focus in the
game
[Music]
some players are just doing it for
fun and to others well it's a personal
thing very very
regardless these moments can add hype to
the crowd which makes tournaments more
exciting and entertaining
[Music]
this video is a compilation of some of
the most disrespectful moments in Tekken
tournaments
I'm Drew and you're watching ochodo TV
[Music]
potential final game now in this set is
ready start
I like how we stayed on the floor though
that was a smart option there yeah
okay here we go oh no sorry dude start
slide dude to start he's so afraid of
the hopkick or the one standing too how
many slides can you do well another one
no these levels of disrespect here for
me
I can hear ak's giggle as that happens
he's gonna do he's still trying to do
the Slime he wanted him one more time
never mind two rounds one AK
[Music]
s
that's why okay
mind games
[Music]
if they will buy it
is
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
oh my God
obviously man this is crazy
foreign
but this game is still good
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
dude
that was impressive that was impressive
considering how badly old top beats
oh my God John thing no
problem
he's rocking he's rocking
[Music]
oh [__] not give him the knot yo this is
about to get good this is about to get
good oh let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God and that's why you don't do
that that's why you don't do that
again
who's looking at the screen that time
oh no
and it's gonna be two rounds great for
jaunting that both of them
wow wow
getting something started oh no one was
gonna kill him okay he's gonna kill it's
gonna kill oh he's looking right back at
him now he quack with the smile he had a
crack a good thing oh not like that it's
not and John ding gonna eliminate whole
shops
[Music]
another healthy
oh my God
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
God
oh no
we're utilizing all of those moves
[Music]
what else can I say about Tim he's been
in SoCal for 10 years he's irrelevant
he's been sponsored by fiber 10 teams
beating Tim and Tekken does absolutely
nothing for me this is just to talk
Tim
what is what I think about running black
as a player I think he's uh pretty free
like Costco samples free like it's not
even gonna be an issue as a person I
think that he talks a lot of trash and
likes to run his mouth so it's time to
shut it up
oh and that's a big red part he runs up
oh
oh the damage it's gonna close it out
oh my goodness for the mid this time
nice break on the throw
oh my goodness oh no don't bring it this
time and the Okie on the wall means
that's going to be it second Tim takes
it three straight
you can see run a block is definitely
not happy about
all right
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]